you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
how do you feel about our chances of
making it to the point to where we could
actually
get out there right far
it's kind of funny because i i mean my
whole excitement about science in
science education there's a dark side to
it where we are
our
our power is increasing exponentially
because of science
yet our wisdom to
you know use it properly
is not growing exponentially yes the
dark side uh
it is a worry i'm i'm more excited than
worried but
um
you you but i think you are right to be
worried
i
i believe in science i think science can
be such a force for good it can be a
force for bad as well if it's misused
the trick of course is to use it well
um it it it's an immensely powerful
weapon
which in the the right hands can do
enormous amounts of good and in the
wrong hands can do enormous amounts of
bad
and and the trick is to keep it out of
the wrong hands
so that was just a clip for my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below subscribe to this
channel if you enjoyed it i upload clips
pretty regularly talks and conversations
and presentations that i've done on
genetics and evolution and i am gearing
up to start doing weekly videos again
here that are completely new completely
fresh